[Music]
[Applause]
residence
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
how's it goin everybody it's Warren
today is a week where we are just
getting a ton of new information about
the Disney Plus Marvel shows obviously
in the Superbowl we got our new trailer
for it and today we have the official
release dates for the upcoming Marvel
Studios Disney Plus shows and if you're
a Mandalorian fan we have the release
date for the second season of that as
well so Disney released the official
release dates for Falcon and the Winter
Soldier the mandalorian season 2 and the
1 division series the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series is going to be
premiering in August of 2020 now this is
going to be after the Black Widow movie
but before the Eternals and Disney has
confirmed that the series is going to be
six episodes long and I think at this
point we can expect that every single
Marvel Disney Plus show is going to be
multiple seasons long of course we know
that the falcon in the Winter Soldier
series is going to be about Sam and
Bucky but we have a new Captain America
u.s. agent John Walker and we know that
Zemo is going to be returning as well
and if you're a star wars and a
Mandalorian fan season 2 is going to be
coming in October so basically around
the same time that the first one
premiered absolutely zero surprise that
we're getting a season two people can't
get enough of baby Yoda and then it's
been announced that the Wanda vision
series is going to be premiering in
December of 2020 now this is moved up it
was originally not supposed to be in
2020 it was supposed to be in 2021 2021
was supposed to go shang-chi and then
the one division series in the spring
but now it's set to premiere in December
right after the release of the eternal
so maybe there's some sort of a
connection there so 2020 is going to be
an awesome year and absolutely
jam-packed the Black Widow solo film is
coming on May 1st the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series will premiere in
August the Eternals will premiere on
November 6th and the one division series
will be coming in December and not to
mention if you're a fan of the
mandalorian that's coming in October of
2020 as well so lots to look forward to
this year which one of these are you
most excited about to see in 2020 let me
know what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to give the video a
like and subscribe what the
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to
and Xbox one or ps4 when I hit 550
thousand subscribers as always thank you
all so much for watching we'll fluff